if you've been looking at buying some
new airpods or especially the airpods
pro you should probably stop even though
there are some good sales on amazon like
20 off only 200 for a pair of airpods
pro you might be making a mistake if you
buy them right now the reason is because
we are getting some brand new leaks and
rumors for the airpods pro 2 that are
going to be coming out very soon with
some massive upgrades as i'm going to
get into in this video but before i get
into the latest leaks and rumors i've
got to go through some of the older ones
because this is very important
specifically because for many months we
thought that the airpods pro 2 would
come with a brand new design
specifically stemless like you can see
in this video that we made six months
ago yes we had some rumors specifically
from mark german who said that we could
be getting a new redesign with the
airpods pro 2 with them eliminating the
stem giving you that stemless flush
design and it wasn't only mark german
ming chukwuo also came out in december
of last year saying that the airpods pro
2 would have a new design and an
improved chip launching in late
2022 so he also agreed that we could
have that stemless design now when i
first heard about this design change i
was a little bit weary about it because
first of all apple really cares about
those physical touch controls like
pinching to skip songs pause double
click triple click whatever on the
actual stem and that helps them be very
reliable and eliminating the stem
entirely would make the physical
controls go away because you'd probably
have to tap like you did on the original
airpods which apple replaced that kind
of functionality and i didn't find it as
reliable and another reason i thought it
was kind of weird is because the stem
has always been the signature trademark
of the airpods and it's what made them
unique compared to all the other earbuds
out there so if apple got rid of it it
would basically be getting rid of the
one thing that makes it very unique and
special however a stemless design would
actually be really cool because you can
change your shirt without kind of
nicking the stem on the airpods and you
can put on a motorcycle helmet and use
them while riding your motorcycle with
transparency mode turned on you still
want to hear what's around you but that
would be kind of convenient because with
the current airpods you can't really do
that however in october of last year mac
rumors received this image from a source
named xerxes with basically no track
record but it showed a new airpods pro 2
case with basically the same design
except for a couple of changes like
adding speaker holes on the bottom to
use with find my and this new little
attachment on the side for attaching
various accessories if you want to kind
of attach your air pods to your bag or
something else and then last month mac
rumors dug in a little bit deeper and
said that the airpods pro 2 are likely
to feature exactly the same design in
terms of the actual buds themselves
contrary to the stemless rumors so why
would apple do this well first of all it
is a lot cheaper to reuse the same
earbud design as they did before because
they don't have to pay for the new
manufacturing the new tooling you just
do the same thing as you did before and
apple is going to be saving a lot of
money and it's going to help the actual
supply chain as well and this is
important for apple because right now
they're trying to increase their profit
margins as much as they can because of
all of the inflationary issues that are
going on and then on top of that if
apple is able to upgrade the internals
of the actual earbuds themselves making
the speakers better making the noise
cancellation better and maybe even
adding lossless audio which i'm gonna
talk about then they could get away with
not changing the design but upgrading
them to airpods pro 2 and people are
still going to buy them and speaking of
lossless audio minchiko came out in the
beginning of this year in january saying
that the airpods pro 2 are going to
feature lossless audio support which is
a big deal because apple has basically
upgraded their entire apple music
library to support lossless audio but
right now none of the airpods support it
not even the airpods max support
lossless audio so because apple made
such a huge effort to bring all the
songs up to par with lossless audio
support and make sense for them to find
a way to make airpods at least the new
ones support lossless audio and i
actually made a video about this six
months ago talking about how apple could
be using some new chip potentially like
the u2 chip or ultra wideband or
something else to bring lossless to the
new airpods pro 2. and just a couple of
weeks ago 52 audio came out with a
massive leak saying that the airpods pro
2 will feature an upgraded h1 ship find
my support heart rate detection
usbc
and more as you can see we have the same
design for the case and the actual air
pods themselves but we're going to be
getting all these upgrades including
sound improvements as well with the
airpods pro 2 sharing the acoustics with
the airpods 3 which do have new dynamic
speaker drivers and extra capabilities
like using them as hearing aids which 52
audio thinks they are going to have and
if you haven't heard of 52audio.com
they're actually extremely accurate in
terms of their leaks because they
actually had the airpods pro first look
leak correct and accurate from the get
go which was awesome revealing the case
and the actual
earbuds and they actually had the
airpods 3 first look leak correct as
well showing off some of the components
of the air pass 3 and they were spot on
including some features like having the
h1 ship not having anc
and some of these other things as well
but the really awesome part is that they
release some images showing off
basically the same case that we saw
before in the previously leaked images
last year with some speaker holes on the
bottom which will be used for find my
and this accessory attachment on the
side but not only that you can see right
here that this is a usb c port which i
think is awesome and i really hope it
does because i was not expecting usbc
accessories to come until after the
iphone 15 lineup next year but there is
a chance that they're going to do it
earlier with the airpods pro because
these will likely be selling for the
next couple of years so they might want
to switch to usbc first before they get
forced to switch
next year by the eu and everything else
now on top of that we also got some
recent leaks from mark german saying
that the airpods pro 2 are no longer
expected to feature built-in heart rate
or body temperature sensors which is a
little bit disappointing because a lot
of people were excited for that but
apple might hold off until they redesign
it again which might not happen for a
few years who knows at this point but
just to add to the whole usb c point
minchiko actually talked about it back
in may saying that apple is going to be
switching all of their accessories
including the airpods magic keyboard
trackpad mouse mac safe battery
everything else to usbc in the
foreseeable future which i totally agree
with and i hope it happens sooner rather
than later and then finally talking
about the release date we did get some
clues from mark german saying that they
are going to be updated this fall which
i totally agree with and i think it's
going to be coming maybe in october or
november but there is a chance they
could come alongside the new iphone 14
lineup i'm not really sure but i think
it is going to be happening sometime
this fall so
if you're interested in waiting for the
airpods pro 2 i think that's going to be
an excellent choice because if these
support lossless audio that is going to
be a huge improvement compared to the
current airpods pro that do not so even
if you can get them on sale for 200
i would honestly just wait a few more
months with the air pods or earbuds that
you have now and just spend the extra
50 bucks who knows maybe they're gonna
be even more expensive three hundred
dollars i mean that'd be crazy hopefully
250 and i think that would be a great
choice now if you disagree with me let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoy the video click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]